so for game two this double header the
brewers are
technically the home team even though
all the stats
in this game will show up as a road game
for milwaukee but uh as this odd season
has turned out
the brewers will get a makeup if you
will for some of those lost games
back here at miller park from earlier
this season and
one pitch one out 2-0 pitch to
goldschmidt
swinging a bouncer hit towards third
gloved by sogard he gets up throws the
first
scoop by jerko they got him
he took an extra base hit away from paul
goldschmidt a heck of a play by eric
silgaard
runner at second base two outs and that
is a massive play in this top of the
first inning
with that play and the speed of tommy
edmond that may have saved a run as well
here's matt carpenter carpenter down the
right field line and a base hit that
will score tommy edmund
and matt on his way to second base one
to nothing cardinals here in the first
on a two out double by carpenter
rome all the right side and has it for
the
out and it's daniel ponce de leon making
his
eighth start of the year and still
looking for a win
as a starter in his major league career
with all the double play
double headers and did a great job and a
fly ball that's lifted out to
center dylan carlson with the catch
shift on the right side yelich a fly
ball
slicing to edmond and he's there to make
the catch two away
and brawn it's a fly ball to dylan
carlson
three fly ball out second game of this
double header
st louis bats first so milwaukee gets
the last ups
seven inning game and miller goes down
on strikes
runners at the corners top of the lineup
cold wong the next two of the cardinals
second baseman
hits him or did it it's a wild pitch
let's hope it didn't hit him
and with that a run will score
apparently it did not hit
wong and wong singles into the gap in
left center field
it's more than a single all the way to
the wall
cold in the second weiner scores coleman
to third with a triple
three to nothing cardinals
[Applause]
swing and a miss in a strikeout four up
and four down for daniel ponce de leon
just like the cards here's a high
fastball a swing and a miss
and down on strikes is here
swing or rather a
called third strike i thought he's gonna
he was ready to pull the trigger
didn't think that was gonna happen after
the first week you know it was
pretty dreadful goldschmidt goes down
swinging good start here in the third
inning for lin bloom
3-2 on the way and called strike three
and claudio
comes in and does his job
here's the one two struck him out so
miller goes down
swinging to open up the fourth here's
the one two
and a strikeout for rasmussen as deyoung
goes down swinging
that's a good slider
and there's a strikeout i'm tommy edmond
edmond with a single and a run score and
he had a fly ball to the warning track
burnout
tommy edmond with a fly ball deep right
center field it's well hit
it is gone it's a home run for tommy
edmond
a two-run shot fifth home run this
season for tommy
and a five-nothing saint louis laid
they'll be effective on the mound but
still
[Applause]
and called strike three nice pitch there
from laura on the inside edge
bases loaded dylan carlson
carlson rips it into left one run is in
here comes dexter de young to third
carlson to second seven nothing saint
louis
three-two pitch wieners a single into
center field one run in
here comes dylan carlson he will score
nine-nothing cardinals in the
2-2 pitch swing and a miss
in strikeout number four for daniel
ponce de leon
down central and the strikeout five
tonight
we're in the bottom of the sixth nobody
out
pitch from ponce de leon swinging a high
fly
center field drifting back vader warning
track wall
gone no hitter gone
the brewers are on the board orlando
arsenal his
fifth home run of the season it's now
9-1
st louis and the 3-2
he struck him out
[Applause]
in the air left field this should do it
going back o'neil on the track and makes
the catch and the cardinals
win it split the double header final of
nine to one